well you have to think it's a giant
metal like cookie roller right yeah and
uh it just missed every vertebrae right
didn't hit any organs didn't my brain
didn't swell nothing like that and my
eye did pop out Jeremy Renner shares the
gruesome details behind the snow plow
accident that almost killed him you know
it did I got very lucky that you know
none of the organs got messed up I
really couldn't be more fortunate the
actor seemed in good spirits walking
into Jimmy Kim alive with a cane and a
smile I speak for all of us when I say
thank God look at you you look great
we're glad to see you here right off the
bat Jeremy describes the New Year's Day
incident when he was run over by a seven
ton snowplow in an attempt to save his
nephew's life I try to jump back on it
to stop it from running him over and
then I got eaten up under the tracks you
got under the snowplow yeah yeah
someone's been run over by a snow cat
hurry he's been crushed okay one
paramedic to ambulance everyone's on the
way right now listen to me you might
want to get a life flight out here
immediately you broke more than 30 bones
yeah it's like 30 35 or so 35 or so yeah
when you have to say or so when you're
counting up how many bones you broke we
kept discovering them as they were going
along as it went from critical order of
you know priority of like what's what am
I going to die from or not and then you
know it was six weeks later finding
another break and another break another
breaks among the most scary injuries am
I did pop out that's that's weird but
yeah but you know it I got very lucky
that you know none of the organs got
messed up pierced your liver though
pierced your liver but that was it
wasn't dangerous you know collapsed lung
yeah that's fine I got another one
dodging yesterday yeah yeah he's he's
doing all right he's doing he's doing
well he's the best best guy and you know
um he's awesome turns out Jeremy's
Marvel pal Rudd kept his spirits up
during his recovery he came by a couple
times in the hospital and always just
making making my day because he's one of
the funniest guys around and the funny
man pulled off quite a surprise he sent
me a video message you know what anybody
knows Cameo where they could pay like
money and get some movie star to say hey
happy birthday so he made a fake one I
just wanted to send this video uh it's
really from the heart and I hope you're
feeling better sounds like you are
apparently you're a pretty tough guy so
maybe I get to meet you one day and uh
wouldn't that be something all the
creators and then just all the talent
involved a really really good solid
amazing human beings
last week Jeremy sat down with Diane
Sawyer for his first interview since the
accident do you remember the pain oh all
of it yeah I was awake through every
moment and it's a it's exactly like you
imagined it would feel like the Hawkeye
star said he's got a new appreciation
for life and when it comes to Future
Marvel movies he's handing over the
reins to the professionals do you dream
of doing those studs again
I'm okay with a stunt guy doing it
support him 52. it's fine I've done
enough I'm okay to do more right but you
know I'm okay I have no ego like yeah go
for it I don't care I'll be in my
trailer
[Music]